dozens of buses stand ready to enter
mario pole
filled with food and water they're
trying to reach one of the areas hardest
hit by russian shelling
their only protection signs on the
windows people in ukrainian
they try to go in but are turned around
i have to say this with pain
mariopol remains blocked by the enemy
russian troops did not let our aid into
the city and continue to torture our
people our mariopo residents tomorrow
we'll try again
once again send food water and medicine
for our city
for nearly two weeks no one has been
able to leave this city
and no aid has entered
we were trapped underground and two
children died norm was able to save them
people here are desperate for help there
are thousands and thousands of families
trapped in this city who are running out
of water and then at that point what do
you do even our team uh the the
international committee the red cross
team
that is in mario poll uh
they've effectively run out of water and
they're telling us okay now we go to a
stream
and collect water we boil it we drink it
well how do
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people do that especially
if you're elderly
these satellite pictures show industrial
and residential buildings flattened
fires still burning ukraine's foreign
minister dimitro kulaba says russia
wants to capture the city at any cost
mariupol is crucially important for
russia because if they seize
control over the city
they will establish a direct land
corridor uh
to
to crimea from russia
and they will also cut us off from
access to azab sea this is why we still
fiercely
and heroically defended
and this is why
russia is so ruthlessly trying to
destroy the city and capture it at any
cost
ukraine says it will not surrender or
retreat
and attempts to reach people trapped in
the city will continue
we will try tomorrow again to evacuate
people from mario paul we will again do
it tomorrow in front of the whole world
in front of the politicians and leaders
in front of the entire planet earth
but for now these buses remain full of
aid but empty of people who want to
leave
leah harding al jazeera